[Music]
we're going to go to washington dc with
michael hey michael how are you
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's going on
hey well first i want to say thanks uh
me and my wife got married a little over
a year ago we've been listening to your
stuff since then and using every dollar
and i think it's actually really helped
our marriage so thank you for that
awesome we love to hear that
yeah it's been a great jump start um but
i'll dive into the question so basically
both of us had a little bit of a scare
with our employment due to the vaccine
mandates
and it kind of caused us to reassess our
financial situation so
we do have a little bit of a savings
but we also have a car loan and a
federal student loan and
we were at first saving for a house so
we have about 65 grand
set aside for a down payment but now
we're wondering um should we
knock out the car loan
just right now get it out of the way
really quick or knock out part of the
student loan
or is it better maybe to just pay the
minimum payments and then save the money
maybe for the next year or so and really
just
build up our savings as much as possible
just in case
uh i don't know if something happens
with the economy or something else
happens with our employment
what do you guys think about that how
much total debt do you have including
the student loans car loans and any any
credit cards or anything else what's the
total
no no credit cards the total debt is
about 140 so it's about 130 for student
loans and 10 for the car gotcha and what
y'all's income
two hundred and thirty thousand oh y'all
make a great income michael you'll make
a great job um are you new to the ramsey
show
um
uh i've been listening kind of on and
off for
probably i have for about two years and
then we started listening together like
i said about a year or so ago cool well
the the reason i ask is because a lot of
times some you know if people are new to
us or you know if you hear the show kind
of in bits and pieces it's easy to get
confused and maybe do the baby steps out
of order and you guys are that's what
y'all are doing you're kind of doing
things out of order with the house
savings and so on so i'm gonna let
george take it from here um but you guys
are in a position to make some good
changes but yeah we definitely want to
do things in a different order to set
you up for success yeah what i'm seeing
here on paper with your income and where
you guys are at you've just been trying
to do a lot of things at once and you're
not seeing the progress that you want to
see so if you've got 65 000 in cash i
know you guys want to get a house and
that's an awesome goal but right now
we've got different priorities we've got
to clean up this debt and so with that
65 000 i'm gonna take 64 of that if
you're doing the baby steps going back
to baby step one we've got a thousand
dollars and the rest we're gonna crush
the credit card debt in half of the
student loan debt just like that car
loan you mean yeah yeah the student loan
that's 130 and the car loan is 10. so
you clean up the car loan today and half
of the student loan debt today which is
amazing and then you get you make 230
000 a year the student loans are gone
under a year with your income if you
guys are getting intense about this
making some sacrifices
once you've got that then we can get
that fully funded emergency fund because
i heard it in your story you guys are a
little worried about the future uh but
when you owe 140 000
you owe other people and so if something
goes down
you're still stuck with those payments
and your income doesn't stay with you
and so i want you to clean up this debt
get that fully funded emergency fund
three to six months it sounds like you
guys should lean towards six months
because of your
job situations
and then that's when you'd start saving
up for a down payment and with that
income you're going to get back to that
65 in no time if you do this stuff in
order because
all of the income is focused on one
thing at a time that is what we teach
that's how we see progress every debt
free scream you've seen they followed
those steps to get there and uh you guys
can do it you have an amazing income and
there is a pile of debt but we can clean
all this up real fast and get you into a
house in a few years the the only other
thing i would add to that michael yeah
because you guys are in such a good
position um to get this knocked out and
cleaned up really quick the only other
thing i'll add to that is it's really
easy to be tempted to make decisions
based on fear when it comes to job
security and you guys had a real scare
for sure but when you when you said
things in your questions like the
economy and this the other we could we
could run what-if scenarios all day and
it's just not beneficial what we want to
do is make decisions based on facts the
fact is today you have a job if you can
see that you have a job for the
foreseeable future then we're going to
operate as you have a job if for some
reason you got some notice that you're
going to be laid off in two months or
there's going to be some vaccine thing
that affects you guys being able to work
there in three months then yeah we would
say okay let's stockpile some cash and
start looking for another job asap but
that's just not the case from what i
heard from your scenario and so i just i
i don't want you to run what if
scenarios i want you to look at today in
the foreseeable future today we have
jobs we have a great income so we're
going to work the baby steps like normal
and not get caught up in those um what
what if scenarios yeah you can clean
this thing up it won't take long
honestly i mean you guys you've got a
big pile of cash and a fantastic income
we just got to start doing things in
order to see that progress yeah and i
know it feels a little scary but i
promise you we teach it in this way
because it works and once you get into
it you'll get motivated you'll get that
debt knocked out and you'll be so glad
you did and then you won't feel that
risk or fear even if you lose job
because you've got a fully funded
emergency fund